All right guys, so here is an example number one of the market maker second distribution entry model
So right here, but do we have we have taken out the external liquidity, right?
This fairly gap is gonna be a drawn look. So let's see what have happened here going to the one-hour time frame
This is when we took out the external liquidity, right?
We have the consolidation right here and we have this drawn liquidity right here
We have this pullback which is the accumulation phase one, right?
You only want to see a small pullback or consolidation. That's pretty much it. So now let's look at it here
After price took out the liquid. What do we have? We have a lower low lower high lower low
Now that's when we get a market structure shift and we also have the first stage of the market maker
Second distribution model complete which is double break of structure, right?
Once you have a double break of structure
You want to wait for a purge of any lower high now what is a lower high?
We have lower low lower high. This is a lower high, right?
But do we have here lower low lower high lower low, right?
Now this is that lower high that you want to put your focus on we took out this
lower high here now
We want to wait for a double break of structure once again, right?
So we have this level taken out. We also took out this level, but this is not necessary
We took out this lower high now. We simply wait for a double break of structure. So what do we have? We have a lower low
Right zooming in here. We have a lower low lower high and a lower low
Once you have that look at where is the unmitigated fair value gap
This right here is the fair value gap that we're talking about now
This is your second distribution entry model and guys
Once you get this set up
There's like no going back, okay, so this is like a live trade
I think we can't play it forward. So like this is happening right now. It happened on
Monday
You can see at three we got the entry and
This is the beauty of this model once you get this type of setup
You have to train your mind to see this type of setup guys. It's not it's not I
Like my other strategies is not easy. It's not like it's like a piece of you know
Cake no, it is not that you have to identify these structures and one more thing to help you with this is
Wicks maker okay in this strategy
So you don't have to wait for body closure if you get a wick
That is your shift in market structure if you get like a wick here and then a wick here
That is your break of structure. So let's say if the body didn't close here
But it was just a wick that was a clean setup. Okay, you don't you can also wait for wicks in this type of strategy. So
This second distribution is complete and we hit this
Almost trying to hit this level. We will take out the slope and this would have been a 14.98
Let's say you put your stop here. Maybe here
Let's say even here three you would get one to three, but usually I would put my stop here
That was 13.46. It happened recently. That was your challenge pass in one trade
Let's move on to the next example